tariffs are awful the tariffs married to
uncertainty is probably even worse
Arizona Senator Jeff Flake is just one
of several Republican senators preparing
legislation to derail president Trump's
plan for new tariffs on steel and
aluminum this is a counterproductive as
well as result in retaliatory actions by
our trade partners and again it just
injects uncertainty to an economy that
was really doing quite well it won't be
easy though the president's acting under
authority to restrict imports through
tariffs for national security reasons
and can do so without congressional
approval and that's assuming Congress
can even get a majority to vote for
blocking the president I do not think
that would even pass you'd have to have
both part of both committees the House
and the Senate pass it it happens veto
by the president have to be override I
don't think that's going to happen part
of House Majority Leader Kevin
McCarthy's pessimism may be based on
numbers overriding a presidential veto
would require the support of 67 senators
and 290 House members and this isn't a
partisan issue several Democrats like
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
support mr. Trump's tariffs I was very
glad to see what the President had done
we have negotiated one deal after
another that has been great for big
multinational corporations and been
lousy for American workers with this
being an election year would seem highly
unlikely that Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell and Speaker Paul Ryan
would take on the president so the only
hope for GOP lawmakers may be trying to
convince the White House to fine-tune
the tariffs if somebody's taking
advantage of us if if our markets are
open and nobody is and they're not
paying tariffs to get into this country
but yet we turn around and have to pay
tariffs to get into their country then
something's wrong with that there is
also a political calculation here with
uncertainty over the impact of taking on
a Republican president who's keeping a
campaign pledge another reason why most
expect Congress will ultimately cave